uh so what's going on in your career man
Shazam is coming out March what 17th
March 17th St Patrick's Day Saint
Patrick
Shazam two what's the what's it called
Shazam Shazam 2 Electric Boogaloo no
it's not I wanted it to be though I
really did
um no Shazam Fury of the Gods that's
what it that's the name of it and um
yeah it's super fun everybody should go
I mean have you seen it yeah oh yeah you
saw it yeah you're smiling it's big it's
big it's bigger than the first oh it's
significantly bigger in in production
and scale and stuff yeah but also heart
it's got a heart well it's got all all
and the first one did it's got all the
I mean I know I'm biased clearly I mean
I'm as the titular character of of a
movie it's very difficult to not be
biased about your movie but but I think
I try to be
as objective as I can when I can
and you know look I watched it there's
still things I'm like I would have done
that different if I or if I had to edit
everyone like this take or that's
whatever but bro holistically speaking I
mean
it's a better movie than the first one
it is and the first one was a pretty
darn good movie so I think that um
[Music]
I mean honestly like I'm
chomping at the bit for people to go and
see the movie because they're going to
see I really think how are they not
going to see this I hope so I believe so
I don't know bro I don't know all none
of this stuff is written in stone you
don't know these things you just you
gotta
humility gratitude and Trust man be
humble to wherever you're at in your
life and recognize that you are where
you are and try to take that in for what
it is always be grateful for what that
is and Trust I think in God in that
higher power in that energy in in all
that is in and through all things like
the forest trust that and recognize
that the more work you're doing on
yourself the better it's able to help
guide you to those dope places
in your life you know